you could say it's just a dream come
true jennifer lopez and ben affleck
celebrated their real-life fairy tales
celebrating their marriage with a
blowout wedding weekend in georgia and
the guest list was star-studded but a
few names were noticeably missing at
benifer's nuptials their a-list exes i
ran into one of my
you know childhood baseball heroes
a fan spotted jen's ex-fiance alex
rodriguez pumping iron in the gym in
miami the day before he seemed
unbothered by j lo's big day lj smooth
telling e.t a-rod was cool inviting and
easy going when he asked the former
baseball pro for a selfie and on the day
of jen's wedding a-rod blew off some
more steam posting another workout pick
to his instagram story i think the
workout i enjoy because it reminds me of
my playing days
meanwhile j lo's ex-husband mark anthony
had some fun soaking up the miami sun on
sunday an eyewitness spot at the singer
saying his goodbyes to staff at the
miami marina where his private yacht is
anchored his fiancee nadia joined him
for the ocean outing she posted a snap
posing on a boat in her bikini while
showing off her view it's unclear if
mark was invited to j.lo's nuptials but
we wouldn't be surprised since the two
remained friends after finalizing their
divorce in 2014 and they continued to
co-parent their 13-year-old twins emmy
and max not ever wanting to in any way
you know say anything negative about him
or our relationship a source told e.t
lopez and anthony are on the same page
quote there is no ill will from anyone
and the mutual goal and focus is zero
drama and to prioritize being great
parents to their children the same goes
for ben's ex jennifer garner they share
three kids the 30 year old actress was
also m.i.a from the wedding held at
ben's 87-acre estate in riceboro georgia
instead garner was spotted out enjoying
a chill weekend grabbing groceries at
sam's club in her home state of west
virginia as a source previously
explained to e.t mark anthony and jen
and ben and jen garner are still getting
along relatively well and share special
places in each other's hearts we have
good days we have bad days but we love
each other through them all and while
most of ben's family was in attendance
including his mom chris ann bolt his
brother casey skipped the festivities
but shared a heartfelt tribute to the
couple who rekindled their romance
nearly 20 years after calling off their
first engagement as casey puts it good
things are worth waiting for and spoken
like a true brother-in-law he officially
welcomed j-lo to the affleck family with
some humor get ready for some real
dysfunction kidding i am kidding jen you
are a gym we love you so much we're
super happy
um
what can i tell you we're just
having a good time
[Music]